welcome to this video playing Jesse from
Finland Kings Indian or grid fault want
to do something else I've played so many
of those classical Kings Indians with
the smart I've gone off with age three
and so on let's do them if you chat
online it's also very reliable set up
for four wide okay i don't i don't know
it though it's a one of the lines i have
never seriously studied yeah maybe you
can play a b5 might have also fi fi
seems unlikely I assume this is this is
one line and so I've seen this before
hmm yeah it's really rook h5 this is
dangerous rocky I can I can play h4 it's
not the end of the world if they look
appears there but
I'm playing age form and maybe you can
start with Bishop 83 by the way okay i
take c 5 Bishop h3 Rather's Bishop g4
the big threat no okay I need to react
to that check okay I really don't know
is this so terrible for white I mean the
rook here okay I cannot take g4s d4
hangs as well so i probably should take
him maybe you could have taken on c3 now
okay don't worry let's just continue
this night is not bad edited stair
treads 97 with the Queen win night f4
maybe and it cannot easily be expelled
night f4 now isn't this a winning the
exchange yes it is I'd wins the exchange
or some other material like this okay
night I can take here though 96 night is
six every six takes on h4 Queen edge
form
yeah it's not not so easy to play it's
probably not objectively working but it
is very dangerous at least get the Queen
to g3 and maybe he can actually yeah
yeah okay this is this is also
interesting but okay it doesn't matter
it's already already over this chance I
thought maybe he could have firm played
on
hmm
okay I wonder about this is this
90-degree I can always take with the
piece on you three and the night is
hanging on 1g form could really be
reactive it's not working I had
subscribe i DM group txt if rookie fate
I don't know about that song
now that's relatively safe I mean I can
always blunder stuff but white has good
control m-my my extra Bishop is some is
helping to defend the king and now queen
d force the IDM he only has one color
one point form for the piece okay cannot
take the six of course maybe five though
the IE five is good can try to get the
Queen side now
hmm
still be seven hangs and b6 roop d6 I
will get the pawn look at 5i can play a
form in forever it's not really that
great know that i think about it then it
can play III it's not a big problem if
he goes in three really okay so he
allows me to take them probably with the
bishop I want to keep keep both pieces
the rook is some may be good to attack
the the pawns here I can always time
morning make sure that the bishop is
protected
check yeah I'm getting b6 which is the
important on here take this on to a 6
this is easier edge controlling the ape
on the HP added ok I'm coming to be 70
this is really quite quite good I can
just take it
black reside the beginning of the whole
operation it was certainly interesting I
mean you know he didn't really intended
to to to sacrifice the material it was
sort of happening accidentally but it
was interesting i hear bishops III was
interesting very strange-looking move
Knight f4 is probably right then the
rook is really terribly misplaced if we
look at this now can easily imagine that
the rupiah is not able to save himself
if we consider this it's quite nice he
took their 95 and now it gets
problematic really 97 I def form the
computer is giving white almost the
decisive advantage it's in a practical
game it's still very unclear let's say
hard to play oh interesting the computer
is very merciless what could be 3m
preparing to take the rookie because it
cannot move as the night hangs I took
though and now played this move and here
I wasn't sure about this move okay evade
because here chess got this check in but
ok there is no problem i have this i
forgot that i have h2 available so this
is not really helping yeah then why does
basically winning in this is a bit town
a bit too much material yeah yeah yeahs
black only has some chances to to
swindle but it's really lost with the
piece down so what went wrong damn i
don't know maybe I was thinking here
when I when I went here that she can
maybe take on age three first is this
may be an idea
tags and know this i know i can take
here okay okay that's very important and
then take the Queen on CH yeah then this
really means that why this better the
computer actually wants to take the the
night but this looked very dangerous to
me ah again with this idea yes this sum
is assessed by very as being very
advantageous for white to our two pieces
and look for the Queen and I have some
nice possibilities yeah but tough to
play in a in a blitz game alright thanks
for watching